the incident number is 3189 31 oh hey
hey shocking footage out of Los Angeles
as body cam video captures the violent
moments a California mother allegedly
intentionally hit her child's Foster
mother with a car then took police on a
highspeed chase which ended in a crash
oh she's going to go over the thing
there at TC into the park here guys hold
the frequency control hold the frey
authorities say the incident stemmed
from a child custody handoff at a Target
parking lot on October 1st in Los
Angeles California according to the LAPD
39-year-old Maisha Scott was there to
meet her child's foster parents for what
was supposed to be a peaceful transfer
of custody but according to a 911 call
the custody Arrangement took a dramatic
turn as the child's Foster father
accused Scott of kidnapping I I I have a
a mom who's taking a child that I have
custody of and I and I need help because
she's getting ready to get into a car
and drive drive off I'm in San Pedro um
I'm in San Pedro right
now you have custody of it like Soul
custody I have soul custody yes and
she's getting ready to pull off in a
vehicle right now she's starting the
she's starting the vehicle up right now
okay and she's D engine and she has them
in a car with no car SE
please oh my god
daughter uh it's a it's a
son is she the mother of the child
uh yeah blackw Hispanic
reian I'm sorry is she blackw Hispanic
reian she's black how old is
she I think she's like 38 what's her
name Mike Mike Scott how did she get how
did she get your
son um it's it's her son but she picked
him up from Friday she picked him up
from school Friday for me what kind of
vehicle is she
in um she's in a u Hall
Silverado are you hard Chuck and what's
the
license
um I can't really see the license right
now I'm trying to make sure he doesn't
she don't leave um all right we'll send
an officer up once officers responded to
the scene to intervene they discovered
Scott visibly frantic outside of the
U-Haul truck me like that I'm in stress
no the please don't call them into place
before you run up on me like that I'm in
stress Okay what's if you need another
help for that don't do that please I'm
begging yall please don't do that don't
do what run up on me look at me I'm
standing here with my hands in my
pockets all right got I understanding
right calm down page I'm I'm calm no
you're not okay what's going on I'm CM
I'm C okay listen to the officer Scott
then explains to the officers her own
version of events that she was having a
difficult time co-parenting with her
cousin who happens to be one of her
child's foster parents and she refuses
to return her 5-year-old son to his
foster parents following a visit all
while the child sits in the back seat of
the U-Haul watching the incident unfold
he's oh didn't you bring back you see
it's just me in my couch you know what
I'm saying so please don't please don't
ma'am' okay we off to talk you know what
I'm saying but if y'all if y'all want to
if y'all want to do this y'all can just
you know what I mean listen I've been
able to say about two sentences here
okay cuz you haven't explain to me or
anything you keep interrup me I already
said I'm in distress already and call
somebody that can help me okay explain
to me what that means to you that means
that the police does not have no control
over this
situation okay I don't know what the
situation is because you haven't been
able to explain anything to me so why
don't you take a deep breath okay and
let's start from the from the beginning
okay all right cuz I just got here and I
just got some information from what
someone told the dispatcher I really
don't everyone say safe I'm not
concerned about anything right now no
one's going anywhere all right but I
need to know why I why I was brought
here so let me ask you a few questions
this is your son correct yes sir okay um
and how old is he five five okay now
explain to me before anything happened
today what's the cussy situation with
your son the cussy situation with my son
was that my cousin take care of my son
and protect him okay by all cause until
his mother gets out of jail and able to
commit obtain custody herself okay so
there is a court order that's saying
this no there was a court order order is
closed so is that who made that decision
was it Department no who made the
decision no I made a decision because I
asked the court can he go with my cousin
because I trusted my cousin okay with
all that that the court was asking the
court asked me did I know anybody that
means if I know
you that means a family member a friend
a neighbor that I might know a nice
police officer from back in the day you
might know anybody in the world to get
that could come get your baby
today
okay so the court gave your
cousin custody of your child no no no
one has custy of my child my child's in
the system meaning he's up for grabs if
I get in trouble they're going to take
him if get in trouble they're going to
take them so no one's right or wrong
here so you have joint custody with with
how does that work out is there a
certain days that you're supposed to
have him and he's supposed to have him
yes we agreed with him he he made up
everything like I'm just saying yes yes
yes yes because he did me a favor okay
let's let's get an understanding that's
why I'm trying to get this understood so
y don't pick sides is this documented
yeah everything is documented that's why
I wanted to have a positive conversation
you have a copy of that document listen
I have a a copy of certain documents I
don't have all the documents in the
world to prove what I'm saying is right
he don't have no documents to saying
that he's right all I did was take the
document that the police um asked me for
okay okay so let's let's Lo let's let's
let's let's avoid that again we we're
talking two different languages and I
don't think we're getting with that okay
so game that's why I'm trying to
understand you no one it just seems like
you don't understand what I'm talking
about he don't understand what I'm
talking about that's why I said don't
run up on me like that to call somebody
that can deal with the situation if you
don't know nobody like that we don't I
don't even I I don't even know who lives
in San Pedro that's why we came to San
Pedro officers were able to get a hold
of the Department of Children and Family
Services who confirmed Scott does not
have custody of the 5-year-old moments
later the body cam cuts to the officers
negotiating a peaceful transfer of the
child to his foster parents give me his
stuff I'm just playing where else he
going to go we're not playing ma' Aisha
we're not playing games sir okay we give
stuff let let his stuff like look that
that's this is very disrespect's his
stuff he knows his stuff this move he
don't have nothing this man stares my
child you know what if you don't give me
his stuff you can keep it no how am I
going to keep it what is that do for my
child well you're not doing anything for
your child okay I'm just asking you
Misha I'm I'm stressed out I'm having a
hard time explain explain to her with uh
Department of Child Family Services okay
come
on y'all doing this to me we're not
we're just y yall did look we're we're
just back he told my son that he not
safe look how he holding my son where's
his
backpack I'm your
angel I love you
son don't fight
relax after the child returns safely to
his foster parents it looks as though
Scott appears to be leaving the parking
lot but then things take take a shocking
turn Scott and her vehicle speeds
through the Target parking lot striking
the Foster mother with her vehicle and
narrowly avoids hitting the officer the
inci number is 3189 31 oh hey hey as
Scott speeds off and drives away the
officers open fire on the vehicle dash
cam video shows officers going on a
high-speed chase in pursuit of their
suspect G Target parking lot officer
daby Capital Target parking lot un
coming
radio you'll pick up westbound Capital
try catch
up 515 U-Haul pickup truck last year
westbound capital
from towards Western let me get a backup
Airship
[Music]
supervisor that up
there okay yeah I'm good are you
okay hey she took her out yeah hey Hope
should shortly after officers are able
to locate Scott's vehicle they notice
she begins to drive with reduced speed
throughout the neighborhood
51 eastbound on Park Western from
Western slow
speed 5:15 slow speed approximately
she up we're going to do the full uh
we'll try to call her out we'll wait for
backup get here that she goes if she
takes off she's not very fast we're
going to clear the car first all right
we have no reason to believe she's hard
right now but we got to be careful with
that right so we'll try again it CU we
got to keep her getting back in the car
the way she's acting all right so we
play my ear go go off of my uh go off
off my all right she later picks her
speed back up racing through stop signs
to evade
[Music]
police officers eventually catch up to
Scott after she crashed into a tree ver
we are hold the frequency here they just
into the
Cur coming back the officers coming back
to gy off I believe there a shepher here
watch out these guys officers approached
the vehicle armed and managed to pull
Scott out of the vehicle stomach stom
hold up hold up up up
up Misha Scott was later arrested and
charge with two counts of attempted
murder one count of assault with a
deadly weapon on a police officer and
one count of felony evading authorities
say the child's Foster mother who was
hit by Scott was treated for her
injuries and is expected to recover the
APD says no other officers were injured
in the incident but the Department's
Force investigation division as well as
the forensic science division are
investigating the officer involved
shooting reporting for long crime
Network I'm Elizabeth Milner